qu'est-ce qui se passe regardez déclaré
c'est obligé l'aide pour la france des
combines pour se réformer c'est quoi tu
sais ça toi max moulis oui oui oui oui
cette compagnie peuvent filer droit
on dort à soi et à prions tous nous
sommes l'honneur de la france
mais croyez moi on va la gagner cette
guerre désertées et vous ne pensez pas
j'espère
vous envoie en syrie tout ce qui est
charpente une fois dans le désert de
damas sera la routine c'est grand et pas
dans la merde on se fond dans le dommage
qu'on soit certain que l'ambiance 1 et
vous avez réussi à rejoindre londres
sont un commando a eu tout seul des
cracks règles persan et cheval de pub
ridicule
nous avons affaire à des professionnels
qui manie nantais les discussions comme
personne ne croit que vous savez pas à
qui vous avez affaire et ont déjà
franchi tous les barrages
s'énerve le gars ça va il a juste trop
chauffer
cet attentat
posez vous la femme que tu prend en
otage nous a appris à visée comme
personne
maintenant je suis un résistant je me
suis dit qu'il faudrait un homme toi de
moi aussi j'ai choisi poney poney c'est
mignon ça se faufile sign crinière et
c'est chouette on jette qu'est ce qui
s'passe regard des dégâts
c'est obligé pour la france non non non
non si si si dans quelques jours on sera
tous en enfer les gars et bas une guerre
au suivant ah là là je ne vois rien je
suis dans le noir c'est bien peur que ma
vue m'empêche de me battre au le morceau
donc la vue c'est bon écoutez moi bien
les tire-au-flanc à moins d'avoir un
handicap physique aux parts et moi j'ai
une couille ça va pas nous avons à faire
des professionnels de manier l'art du
mensonge et du déguisement l'apparition
d'un commando à eux tous seuls des
cracks enlevée en même temps ils sont
très forts
nous on n'a rien vu venir
allez on y va on y va